[Musique]
parce que le gouvernement n'a pas le
courage de prendre position on l'a vu
ces derniers jours où différents membres
du gouvernement pour des positions
complètement opposées madame aux rideaux
qui est pour le port du voile en
compétition sportive valencia pas qui
est opposé donc c'est la cacophonie et
le gouvernement ne veut pas prendre
position et je pense que c'est comme
d'habitude beaucoup de discours mais pas
le courage d'aller jusqu'au bout une
position floue et ambiguë et un petit
peu lâche qui ne peut pas donc plus
fermer les yeux sur ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans les terrains de sport
et autour des terrains de sport on sait
qu il se passe des choses aussi bien
dans les vestiaires que sur les des
salles adjacentes au terrain de sport où
aujourd'hui certaines personnes font des
prières
portent des tenues religieuses sur les
dents des équipements sportifs lors des
compétitions ce n'est pas acceptable et
on voit bien les fédérations aujourd'hui
sont en première ligne lors certaines
fédérations comme c'est le cas pour la
fédération française de foot ont refusé
et se retrouve aujourd'hui on
conseillerait pas une association a
attaqué la décision de la fédération
d'autres
voilà par manque de textes législatifs
20 acceptent des compromis mais ce qui
pose des vrais problèmes et des tensions
sur les terrains donc tout ça est
vraiment mauvais en ce moment je pense
qu'au contraire le sport est un lieu où
les gens doivent se retrouver partager
et pas être un lieu où on fait de
séparatistes ou certains portent des
signes religieux d'autres pas c'est pas
comme ça que je conçois la pratique du
sport en france
à
[Musique]